c'est dans cet immeuble que jean
françois bélanger a acheté son condo il
y a trois ans sa première propriété un
gros investissement oui j'ai étiré
l'élastique au maximum j'étais
confortable au tout début même s'il a
contracté une hypothèque à taux variable
il ne crée pas trop les hausses de taux
d'intérêt qui pointe à l'horizon j'ai
moins d'inquiétude surtout sachant qu'il
met versement vont rester les mains
c'est juste que malheureusement
évidemment ils recrutent d'intérêt
mais d'autres pourraient être pris au
dépourvu si leurs paiements
hypothécaires grève du jour au lendemain
comme l'immobilier au monté beaucoup
ceux qui ont acheté récemment qui ont
poussé un peu la note mais c'est sûr que
là le paiement mensuel il va arriver
vite le pari mais vite il va faire mal
depuis le début de la pandémie le taux
directeur de la banque du canada est au
plancher en un quart de point pour
stimuler l'économie mais 22 mois plus
tard c'est un coup de frein dont elle a
besoin puisque l'inflation frise des 5%
du jamais vu depuis le début des années
90 la banque centrale doit donc relever
ses taux on pourrait voir que trois à
cinq ans de cette année c'est un sentier
de auch l'inde hong kong leur en avoir
plusieurs on pense pas que c'est une
catastrophe économique qui ne garde
c'est juste une normalisation de la
politique monétaire
la hausse des taux d'intérêt pour
objectif de réduire la demande pour les
biens et services ce qui devrait en
retour faire baisser les prix c'est un
geste qui pourrait bénéficier à ceux qui
sont durement touchées par l'inflation
comme les retraités qui ont des revenus
fixes et tous les autres qui doivent se
serrer la ceinture
les dépenses les loisirs également
d'autres facteurs pourraient aussi
contribuer à la réduction des pressions
inflationnistes
on s'attend à ce qu'elle est une
entreprise plus de mieux en mieux
produire à plus faible coût qui est
moins de problèmes de chaîne
d'approvisionnement moins de contraintes
au jour le jour un lien que la pandémie
donc on mise beaucoup sur ses effets
alors pour réduire l'inflation
la banque du canada devrait s'adonner à
un exercice d'équilibriste dans un
climat d'incertitude ici olivier bachun
radio canada montréal